>> Laura: FORMER
PRESIDENT OBAMA DIDN'T JUST
ATTEMPT TO REMAKE HIS OWN PAST
BUT ALSO THE SUCCESS AMERICA
ENJOYED IN THE AFTERMATH OF THE
COLD WAR.
WATCH.
>> THE WASHINGTON CONSENSUS,
WHATEVER YOU WANT TO CALL IT,
GOT A LITTLE TOO COMFORTABLE
WITH, LOOKING AT GDP NUMBERS AND
LOOKING AT THE INTERNET AND
EVERYTHING IS LOOKING PRETTY
GREAT.
PARTICULARLY AFTER THE COLD WAR.
AFTER WHAT YOU ENGINEERED, YOU
HAVE THIS PERIOD OF GREAT
SMUGNESS ON THE PART OF AMERICA
AND AMERICAN ELITES THINKING WE
HAVE IT ALL FIGURED OUT.
>> Laura: JOINING ME NOW,
REAGAN HISTORIAN CRAIG SHIRLEY.
YOU WERE PARTICULARLY STRUCK BY
FORMER PRESIDENT OBAMA'S
HISTORICAL ILLITERACY.
PLEASE EXPLAIN.
>> LAURA, I CAN'T UNDERSTAND WHY
HE WOULDN'T BE SMUG ABOUT THE
WINNING OF THE COLD WAR.
WE WON THE COLD WAR.
WE DIDN'T END THE COLD WAR.
WE FREED MILLIONS OF PEOPLE
FORMERLY IMPRISONED BEHIND IRON
CURTAIN.
WE TORE DOWN AN EVIL EMPIRE.
RONALD REAGAN LITERALLY CHANGE
THE WORLD.
WE SHOULD HAVE BEEN SMUG.
ONE OF THE GREAT FAILINGS, WHEN
THE WALL FINALLY FELL AND
GORBACHEV RESIGNED, THE
GEORGE H.W. BUSH ADMINISTRATION
NEVER WENT ON NATIONAL
TELEVISION TO EXPLAIN TO THE
AMERICAN PEOPLE WHY THE
ANTI-COMMUNIST POLICIES OF
HARRY TRUMAN, DWIGHT EISENHOWER,
JOHN KENNEDY AND EVERY PRESIDENT
GOING FORWARD AND WHY THE
POLICIES, 55,000 BOYS DIDN'T DIE
IN VAIN IN VIETNAM.
THE LONG TWILIGHT STRUGGLE
AGAINST SOVIET COMMUNISM.
>> Laura: TIE IT ALL TOGETHER.
>> EXACTLY.
WE SHOULD HAVE BEEN SMUG.
WE WON.
THE GOOD GUYS WON AND THE BAD
GUYS LOST.
>> Laura: YOU ARE SMUG TODAY
WHEN YOU PASS OBAMACARE.
THAT IS SOMETHING TO BE REALLY
SMUG ABOUT.
CRAIG, I'VE GOT TO PLAY
SOMETHING ELSE FOR YOU.
IDENTITY POLITICS WAS DISCUSSED
AT LENGTH LAST NIGHT AND THE
NEED FOR CIVILITY.
LIKE WE HAD STABILITY DURING
OBAMA OR IN THE RECENT PAST AND
NOW WE HAVE NO CIVILITY
APPARENTLY BECAUSE OF FOX NEWS
AND TALK RADIO.
THIS IS WHAT HE SAID ABOUT
IDENTITY POLITICS AND WHERE IT
ALL BEGAN.
LET'S WATCH.
>> WHEN I HEAR PEOPLE SAY THEY
DON'T LIKE IDENTITY POLITICS,
THEY DON'T LIKE -- I THINK IT'S
IMPORTANT TO REMEMBER THAT
IDENTITY POLITICS DOESN'T JUST
APPLY WHEN IT'S BLACK PEOPLE ARE
GAY PEOPLE ARE WOMEN.
THE FOLKS WHO REALLY ORIGINATED
IDENTITY POLITICS WITH THE FOLKS
WHO SAID 3/5 CLAUSE, NO LESS
STUFF.
THAT WAS IDENTITY POLITICS.
JIM CROW WAS IDENTITY POLITICS.
THAT'S WHERE IT STARTED.
>> HE TALKED ABOUT JIM CROW IN
THE CONTEXT OF THE
AMERICAN REVOLUTION, JIM CROW
WAS 100 YEARS LATER AND WITHOUT
THE FRAMEWORK THAT WAS CREATED,
THE BRILLIANCE OF THE FRAMERS IN
PHILADELPHIA, HE NEVER WOULD
HAVE BEEN ELECTED PRESIDENT.
WE WOULDN'T HAVE HAD THE CHANCE
TO PASS THE 13TH AND 14TH
AMENDMENTS TO THE CONSTITUTION.
TO ATTACK THE FRAMERS IN
FOUNDERS THIS BEING MIRED IN
IDENTITY POLITICS, THE
AMERICAN REVOLUTION WAS ABOUT
ESCAPING THE IDENTITY POLITICS
OF THE BRITISH EMPIRE WHERE
BRITISH SUBJECTS HAD RIGHTS AND
AMERICAN SUBJECTS HAD NO RIGHTS.
I CAN'T THINK OF ANY BETTER
EXAMPLE OF IDENTITY POLITICS
THAN THAT.
>> Laura: SO HE WENT A PRETTY
GOOD SCHOOLS, RIGHT?
CREDIBLY WELL EDUCATED.
>> DID HE CRACK A BOOK?
>> Laura: EVERYONE COMPLAINS.
ALL THE THINGS THEY COMPLAIN
ABOUT TRUMP, THAT HE DOESN'T
READ ENOUGH HISTORY, ALL THE
THINGS THE ELITES -- HE'S
NARCISSISTIC, THIN-SKINNED,
OBSESSED WITH HIS OWN -- WHAT A
PERSON WHO RUNS FOR PRESIDENT,
EXCEPT FOR REAGAN MAY BE,
DOESN'T HAVE AN OUTSIZED EGO.
THEY ALL DO.
FOR ALL THE THINGS THEY
CRITICIZED TRUMP FOR, WATCHING
OBAMA LAST NIGHT.
HE HAS A COOL APPROACH AND HE'S
A COOL CAT BUT COME ON.
HE IS SO MAD ABOUT TRUMP'S
SUCCESS.
HE IS SO ENRAGED THAT THINGS
HAVE GONE REALLY WELL IN THE
ECONOMY.
SO HE HAS TO SAY I DID IT.
I FIND THAT TO BE -- IT'S JUST
NOT THAT MATURE FOR SOMEONE WHO
FANCIES HIMSELF AS MATURE KIND
OF ELITES, WELL EDUCATED
INDIVIDUAL.
>> HE SAID SOMETHING CURIOUS.
HE SAID NO ONE WAS INDICTED.
YOU JUST WENT THROUGH A WHOLE
LITANY OF SCANDALS.
OBAMA'S EIGHT YEARS IN OFFICE.
ONE THING THAT YOU OVERLOOKED
WAS THE CRIMINAL USE OF THE IRS
TO SHUT DOWN --
>> Laura: THAT WAS ON THE
LIST.
LOIS LERNER.
GIVE ME A BREAK.
>> HE SAID NO ONE WAS INDICTED.
IT'S LIKE SAYING I SHOULD GO ON
MOUNT RUSHMORE BECAUSE I DIDN'T
ROB BANKS.
THAT'S NOT REALLY SOMETHING TO
REALLY BOAST ABOUT, TO SAY NO
ONE WAS INDICTED.
>> Laura: HAS THE NOBEL
COMMITTEE EVER BEEN THE SAME
SINCE PRESIDENT OBAMA WON THE
NOBEL PRIZE?
>> NO.